(easy listening music
and children playing)
- When I was working
as a registered nurse,
I was also traveling to many
different parts of the world.
And that's where I realized
that these hospitals
don't have any medical supplies
to take care of patients.
And that's really when I said to myself,
I'm going to figure this problem out.
And that's what I've done.
My name is Elizabeth McLellan,
and I'm the president
and founder of Partners for World Health.
Our healthcare system is
extremely complicated.
There are many federal rules
and regulations in our country.
And as a result of that,
all healthcare centers
have to discard medical supplies
because they may have been
in a patient's room.
These are not used medical supplies.
They are clean, they are unopened,
and could be used in the developing world.
I started collecting
medical supplies in 2007.
And because there was
no place to store them
in the healthcare facilities,
I started to take them home.
My cellar filled up from
the floor to the ceiling,
and it overflowed into
the downstairs bathroom
until there was just a little
path that I could follow.
And then, eventually,
in September of 2009,
I put my money in to
rent the first warehouse.
And there are so many people
that have joined with us
on this to keep it going.
So it has a life of its own
now, which is pretty exciting.
(upbeat chamber music)
We load the containers
with 15 to 18,000 pounds
of discarded medical supplies.
We collect these discarded
supplies now from all over
the state of Maine,
New Hampshire, Vermont,
and 15 hospitals in Massachusetts.
And we bring them up here to
our distribution warehouse
where we sort through
all of these supplies.
We package them, check expiration dates,
and we ship the container loads
over to different countries
in Asia and Africa, the
Middle East, all over India
and Pakistan, Sri Lanka, et cetera.
(soft piano music)
After the hurricane in Puerto Rico,
we identified that there
was a huge need down there.
And so we are shipping
the fourth container
of medical supplies to be
distributed in Puerto Rico.
(laughter)
- We have a model that works,
so there's a way to do this.
If I can collect one
bag of medical supplies,
now look what's happened.
And so it's important that
we recognize that there are
so many people in our
world that would benefit
from these discarded medical supplies.
So, that's why I'm doing this.
Because it's very important
to me that we try to reach out
and be committed to something greater than
our own self interests and
make a difference in our world.
(flowing orchestra music)